[Music]
campus revs person that is lost ammonium
bakken organ began Delaney upon heating
so particular ragi semiya Heaton nama
saya we resumed our sire the tournament
money the Indonesia
[Music]
buggy or annyeong pitamah Malia I am too
many to dsr to pass Takagi
yeah back to Thomas Emily at me
attractive cenk Uygur Knesset jacket it
wasn't at all
and I am meters I am Hitomi 2-axis top
to get a bloom panna cotta but Ursula
device' sciatica see the petite girl get
a mole I hate Amon but I am too many
knee karna melanin pigment pigment
melanin ammonia like known what I am a
partner then be her melanin pathogenic I
am an American America when JD I am
Young Saeng Akita hargh I am Germany to
variety program to Paula Paula Casillas
sakaram Duga Hagana secretary so cool oh
sorry dude
Goethe I am great bagus Baba condom and
then boom bah bah kut ananga it's a
giraffe buggy for me likhna or octopod
Nia this boots burger paneer here when
your master pan cam Nikita
kama study companion mystic the I am in
Taba me monkey tamil malaika Hoban and
chemistry to boomin young hunter about
Tintin and I am color catalog is
stressed like ice hockey like in Guyana
Bagheera
I am need to go Equus ferus Yamaha
allocate venison and yeah I am India
bogus I am ow but connect I am Tanana
Alaska top the Bhangra then what I
forgave organization arrest warrant
granular Vyasa Messiah from the top to
lose focus
di am Japan
this is the attwater's prairie chicken
a century ago there were a million of
them roaming around today less than 100
are left in the wild and are considered
one of the most endangered birds in
North America
they are native to the coastal areas of
Texas and Louisiana attwater's prairie
chickens are small averaging about a
foot and a half in size and weighing two
pounds
they prefer short and tall grass in
their habitats and have a diverse diet
including grass roots flowers seeds and
insects urbanization and other forms of
habitat loss have been one of the major
factors in the steep decline of their
population the Houston Zoo runs one of
the captive breeding programs to help
reintroduce these critically endangered
birds to the wild this is the attwater's
prairie chicken the diversity and the
range of Flemish patterns and colors and
forms of the chickens are just
fascinating you really got to like it
it's been a dusty dirty noisy
very noisy but it's sort of fun
gratifying in this way
[Music]
I'm Tom whiting owner and founder of
whiting farms in Delta Colorado
repulsive genetics and production
company that specializes in fly tying
feathers for reasons I can't even
remember why I started raising poultry
when it's about ten years of age and I
just never cease to find it an
interesting subject I'm sure most people
think they know what feathers are really
feathers are a highly specialized
elongated reptilian scale it's just
evolved into feathers a major function
is sexual selection meaning that the
roosters have very brilliant and very
showy feathers so the rooster with the
finest feathers might get the most hands
and those feather traits get increased
over time it takes almost a year to grow
the roosters from baby chicks
I think we've settled in the 80,000
rings at any one time chickens because
they're small and they reproduce very
quickly we can radically alter how the
birds would grow their feathers it's
amazing how much with selection the
birds can have their feathers change
over times and generations this one's
going to Colorado Salt Lake City
Massachusetts Sweden Germany Norway
Wales
Denmark Kenya this whole order right
here I know is going waiting to go to
Japan rooster feathers are used in tying
fishing flies or they have been for
hundreds of years we know because
they're a defensive feather so they have
some rigidity to them that rests on the
surface tension of the water and it
looks like an insect to the fish and the
fish will see it and the dimples it
makes in the water and the
want to strike that and that's the way
the fisherman catches the fish one of
the reasons I'm in this business is I
like just dealing with the birds I find
them endlessly fascinating and my
favorite time of day is often when I'm
going out through the burbs on a daily
basis and looking at them seeing how
they're doing and I feel like I know
them intimately and I handle every bird
in the system I've seen the trajectory
or the arc of where the feathers have
come from but I don't view this as
something that I'm doing it's rather I'm
doing it for a while and I feel a
responsibility to cultivate them in a
responsible way
protect them from diseases so they don't
get wiped out and so they will be
available for as long as people want to
tie fishing flies
[Music]
contingent on to demonic disc you to be
fair I once ever kiss kurudavva
jam'iyyah it's about pooja on the debt
[Music]
at only 24 years old GFX today is aboard
a 30-foot boat sailing around the world
completely on his own know what
sensitive then what happened if you took
a TV effexor so tuna muna found lemon
kidnapper kill iPad welcome sir the
plenty the Uncle Cap'n Pearson a where's
themself as you can accumulate can come
in on the Stars say Ozzie vanilla he
left his home in France two and a half
years ago to begin his journey Geneva
Devon Hispanic ready Phil dr. yellow as
you normally could African election evil
okay Eva yeah question I've ever known
who is the unknown vehicle if it's gonna
tell you pathology knowest not proper to
the Atlantic Parliament passes with
fellow partner on the telomeric of it an
olive oil service terminabro also had
the whole to of course
Shampoo part experience also a mutiny
Miriam buco motivation but the to sir my
senses Union concealment super although
he's been navigating alone he's found an
unlikely companion she can accompany the
unique so heavy that I'm cool I remember
vibrato
no Peter Johnson ooh okay de expertos
I'm a very oppressive see alice kessane
Papa Panov Oh Monica juvie or canary el
permiso Salvatore Momo - Anna is a
virtual monopoly van psycho doctor
Oh Tandy a canopy Telesca Bakunin Unni
Unni Chewie Embry Soraka Moses Posada
totally Zambia effect movie naw nee
situation typically T equal to Q so MA
assalamo cannot Arizona city via
national taken on a glass too
demonstrative a taco
Takumi second viento succeed mmm
DiMaggio don't remember to appear to be
broken someday Rocca Colonna evolution
is over to Oliver's Academy moody kupuna
villaggio Carrasco
[Music]
[Music]
chicken you can eat it for breakfast
lunch dinner and dessert yes I said
dessert venom is my mom attack Bora
Szechuan dockable Michelle Thomas McKean
is Kanak my leverages Mahmood is the
manager master chef and
second-generation owner of this charming
pudding shop one of the puddings they
specialize in is Tuvok gosu also known
as chicken breast pudding ooh Chuck nice
kid Daniel Santos mahogany baby togusa
ot named Amber Lee Yahweh co-wash en
Larissa toddler stay baklava restrictor
mama de todo solarek mr. bokun Puna
ayatul terrace Tokyo by Sebastian Jia is
a bodacious intricate it is step one
boil chicken just enough to take apart
the white meat and then move on to step
two makes water buffalo milk with some
cow's milk like you do and get that
boiling once that boils you can move on
to step 3 add in some broken rice and
once that starch is mixed with that
water buffalo milk you've got yourself
an emulsifier and that my friends is how
you make two vuko su chi o Aldens
umbrella vomited Nepean burner Josiah
told AC demios nice in there
I'm all that we're missing Canaria
nutritious check amazing flavor
check check and the people of Turkey
really love it yeah Annika bernadinem
year after that and hasn't done
can I use Tony for language usually
tenemos una mystery visit chakra in
Jesus al deserved a mootools
they then Varga Jim is a severe campus
save Eric energy optimism on foodon a
mechanical de yada boom de ah da they
were made delicious
[Music]